how to stand out
i got a great question from one of my
youtube video watchers
prince who wrote in to say hey evan you
are great
i'm a businessman i have a lot of
competition with others i always find it
difficult
to win them over hey man i need your
help
so how do you stand out okay this is
such an important question because it's
it's something that we face
all the time as entrepreneurs how do we
beat the competition how do we get
noticed and stand out and so many of you
are in competitive fields
and you're doing nothing to stand out
and separate yourself nothing
important and if you don't do that
you're going to be
mediocre you're going to be average at
best the way to stand out is to make it
personal
and that's not just throw a picture up
right that's a start but make it person
make me feel something
you look at industries that are super
super competitive i don't know what
industry prince is in but you look at
you look at real estate agents you know
you look at financial advisors
you look at industries where you're all
selling the exact same stuff
so you can't stand out on the product
a product is a great way to send out but
if you are offering all the same product
then you can't stand out on that the way
to stand out
is to make it personal so
real estate agents it's not just putting
your face on a sign
that doesn't make me feel personally
connected to you
tell me why you started this business
make me feel something
right one of my favorite stories is um
of a buddy my name's steve i've told it
a few times and steve is a financial
advisor okay he helps people
make investment decisions are you
kidding me man you know how many
financial advisors there are
there are tons of financial advisors
right everybody is a financial advisor
everybody's a part-time financial
advisor so how do you stand out
i was talking to steve like steve you've
got to combine your passions you gotta
you gotta
find something else besides financial
advising that you could tie
in to make you different because
everybody's doing this thing man
you gotta stand out and so his thing was
hockey
and at the start like hockey like what
does hockey have to do with financial
advising
right but steve's the kind of guy who
can watch
sportscenter and watch hockey replays
and watch the same goal
20 times and still love it and his wife
looks at him he's like steve you're
crazy
what are you doing but he loves it if
you start talking hockey to steve
it's over this is a fantastic
find and you may think at the start what
the heck does hockey and financial
advising advice have to do with each
other
but it's the way for him to stand out
because you know what he does now you
look at
financial advisors they try to target
high net worth individuals right
you want you want a portfolio people
have millions of dollars not
ten thousand dollars and so who who does
it go after now
hockey players he goes after
professional
nhl hockey players and they have
millions of dollars
and he has an in because when he's
talking to them
he's a huge hockey nut and so are they
and if he's going up against other
financial advisors who just see them
with a big ticket
but don't really care about hockey that
much they're not going to win steve is
going to win
every time and once he starts working
with a few of them
they pass his name on say yeah you got
to work with this guy
he really gets it that's how he stands
out
and he's able to win huge deals
in a massively competitive field because
he is
different because he brings himself
to his business because he combines his
passions
how boring is your business right now if
i go to your website can i click to
learn more about you
what does it tell me if you're giving me
a boring corporate bio
with a boring corporate picture or no
picture
you're not hitting me tell me why you
started this business tell me why it
means something to you
if you can do that then if i'm looking
at your service compared to everybody
else i'm gonna pick you because i feel
like you care
because i feel like i can connect with
you that's what you need
that's how you stand out and it doesn't
matter how competitive the field is
because there's always room for quality
at the top and when you
combine your passions and you find that
right fit it's gonna be more
fun for you too how much fun does steve
have working with nhl hockey players
imagine if you were only working with
ideal clients who had the same
interests and passions as you you would
love your job you would get referrals
naturally
your business would explode naturally
so stop trying to be corporate stop
trying to be like everybody else
inject some personality some love some
feeling into your company
and you will stand out and start to grow
believe for those of you watching like
the video give it a thumbs up below
i'm a little riled up you got me a
little angry but it's an important topic
let me know what you think leave a
comment ask a question underneath and
click on my face to subscribe to the
channel and see more videos like this
thank you so much i'll see you soon